what's going on everybody gets worn and
today is an amazing day we have our very
first look at Robert Pattinson in the
fool bat suit and it looks absolutely
amazing check out this official video
that was just released by Matt Reeves
the director of the Batman himself
you
now as you can see he looks absolutely
incredible the Batsuit is actually very
modern and it looks like it's actually
kind of armored eyes but at the same
time it's actually pretty stealthy it's
not like Ben Affleck's armor in Batman
vs Superman so it has a heavy armor
aspect to it but it's still flexible and
apparently according to some recent
reports were supposed to see Batman in
this time be in his second year only of
being Batman
so as time goes on of course his suit is
going to evolve but this suit is
absolutely incredible
but this suit is absolutely incredible
for only his second year as Batman but
again when you're a rich billionaire
like Bruce Wayne is it's not that hard
we get our first look at the bat symbol
right there on his chest looks amazing
and Robert Pattinson himself
looks like an awesome Batman so this is
our first look at Matt Reeves as the
Batman coming next year in 2021
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below does it meet
your expectations or is it better
because to me it's so much better than I
thought so let me know what you think
about this also don't forget to like
this video and subscribe and
notifications turned on so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof